Okay, so, in this quiz we're going to pretend that you're
at Redi Memcached and at the heart of Memcached there's a
dictionary. It's a big hash table. So, what I'd like you
to do is implement these four main Memcache functions. We just
talked about three of them, set, get and delete and
I'd also, also like you to write flush. Let's go through
what each of these should. So, set takes two parameters, key
and value. And it sets the value of key in cash
to equal value, and it returns true after setting the
data. The importance will become apparent in the next quiz. Get
takes a key and if the value is in the
cash it returns the value, and if it's not in the
cash, it returns none. Delete takes a key and it
deletes that key from the cache. And flush takes no parameters,
and clears the entire cache. And so, the behavior you should
see after you've implemented this, so if you were to set
x to one, it would return true. If you were to get x, it would return
one. Because we just set at the one, if we were to get y which doesn't exist,
we would see none. And if we were to delete x and then get it, we would
see none. None of these functions should be
particularly complicated, go ahead and give that a try.